oh wow
wow
the slap heard round the world last
night at the 94th academy awards and
well this morning the internet is still
buzzing still buzzing over this we have
film critic derek sante from review
nation joining us to kind of chat about
oscars and derek after two years it's
finally back in all of its glory and
that is what people are talking about
what happened well i mean what it comes
down to
uh is will smith i think the word's
gonna be boiling point i mean there's a
lot of things have been happening of
course all the stories around him
surrounding his marriage his love life
his relationship all that coming
together and then of course his wife uh
medical issues his family i think it's
just one of those things that at the end
of the day he's just
tired of it all and it was just a
boiling point issue as well a lot of
people out there especially their nets
going crazy
and they're deciding whether of course
uh you know violence is always the wrong
wrong answer um but there are also a lot
of people out there who are saying you
know
the one non-negotiable is leave my wife
alone
you know leave my family alone what
about stage though a lot of people are
saying this
and it could be fake and it could be
staged i just don't know chris rock is
that good of an actor
okay so he's not going to be winning the
next award i don't know let's talk about
awards because that is predominantly
what we're supposed to be talking about
this morning um
what a big night you nailed it we talked
friday and you said here's what's going
to win and so there were really no big
surprises there weren't any big
surprises of course there's always a
chance for something to come out
that we wouldn't have expected but
really this year especially with um the
fact that there were less films being
released because of post covid um that
we are definitely looking at a certain
number but kota was always my favorite
all the way back to sundance when it was
sold for 25 million apple tv plus apple
tv is patting itself on the back the
first streamer to win netflix has been
trying for the best picture for a while
and it's not a big deal it's a big deal
it's a big deal 100
and co of course uh troy kotzer for best
supporting best picture and then best
adapted screenplay too so huge huge
night for coda 100
and and that's the thing you know if
you're looking for a good film i think
koda is definitely going to be a choice
for you but our real uh question is
going to be you know do you want to buy
the streamer that's the key that is the
question okay um best actress uh that
was what jessica chastain jessica
chastain eyes of tammy fay and that was
an amazing role and the problem is
when you look at
jessica chastain and you look at the
poster for isaac tammy faye it looks
like it's going to be off-kilter and
weird and it is at times too but it is
an amazing job and she did amazing in it
so if you want there are things like
that that are definitely going to be i
think they're on hbo max right now
so yeah so so eyes are tammy faze on
there dune is on there nightmare alley
by guinemo del toro is on there as well
so there's a lot of ways to watch oscar
films already because a lot of them are
already out oh derek there's so much i
need to watch um and i know i have to
send it back to the desk but really
quick if there was just one pick for
people at home who haven't seen any what
would you say you have to watch i would
have to say it's probably going to be
coda okay code is one of those films
that it makes you want to be a better
person and that's what art is about
sometimes i love it derek sante thank
you for joining us this morning and i
know nate as they send it over here to
the desk you are a huge fan of coda as
well absolutely it's just an incredible
different kind of a movie and like derek
just said it's a feel good movie yes